>> I CAN SEE THAT ALREREEIGHT HE
BY PAUL ANTHEY SCORE
A A E BREAK OUTCOMING IN
AND OVERLAPPING, CROSSING.
JUST ABOUTH TEAMS CHANGING THE
PERSONNEL AS YOU
THIS GAME WITH SOM
OPPORTUNITIES.
A NICE SHOT BY B
SPEEDS OUT O HIM
>> A GREAT PLA
CAPITALS IN PRETTY GOOD SHAP
UNTIL THHE FROZE THE GOALTENDE
BECAOR THE
MOST PART.
>> OVECHKIN, THE SNAPSHOT THAT
GOES WIDE AND LOOKING FOR
DEFLECTION T TG OU ENTERTAININGA
SENATORS TODAY
ROAD TRIP AHEA AS THEY CAME ACRS
D
THEY NEEDED TO KILL TO GET BAC
INTO THI SECONDS ON TH
POWER PLAY
IS OUT PAST SAMSONOV WITH S THEE
THE MASTER OF THAT ANDREA BIG TE
SAMSONOVG SURE THEE GOALIE STICG
U
SHOWING YOU THE.
IN FACT FOR OTTAWA, ALL THRE
GOALD THAT ONE EARLY ON IN
FEHERP
IT
SNAPSHOT AND
CONNOR BROWN, THG THROUG
CENTER
DROPS IT O, AND RIPS
IT THROUGH THE BODY.
AND MAKES IT
>> THAT WAS UCK TO
DEFLECT IT
AND SIX ON FOUR FOR ANOTHER 20
SECONDS WITH THE NET EMPTY
D THEY
STRUCK AWAY.
>> AND SOME PRETTY ROUTINE
PLAYS,